vídeo pasado no fui ni la mitad de
fluido de lo que me hubiera gustado
principalmente porque creo que tras 15
minutos de vídeo mi cerebro se empieza a
sobrecalentar pero bueno lo que quiero
hacer en este vídeo es aclarar lo que
dije ya habíamos encontrado un intervalo
de confianza déjame ponerlo por aquí
teníamos confianza del 95% de que no
sabes que deja de escribir el intervalo
de confianza otra vez entonces teníamos
un intervalo de confianza de 95% para
este parámetro para la media de esta
distribución entonces del 95% para la
media de x 1 - no que aquí que tengo que
escribir tengo que ponerle x 1 barra
menos x2 barra entonces vimos que este
intervalo era un 1.91 más menos 1.21
ahora cerca del final del vídeo pasado
intenté explicar por qué esto estaba
padre no se ve de golpe porque esto es
un parámetro extraño la media de las
diferencias de las medias muestrales
entonces pues parece ser un poco confuso
pero déjame retomar lo que vimos en
vídeos pasados
este parámetro de aquí la media de la
diferencia de las medias muestrales o
sea muy de x1 barra menos x2 barra
vimos hace dos o tres vídeos que era
igual a la media de x1 barra o sea va a
ser igual a la diferencia de las medias
es decir a mu de x1 barra menos mu de x2
barra y además ya hemos visto múltiples
veces que esto es lo mismo que la media
muestral de cada uno de estos es lo
mismo que la media poblacional entonces
es igual a digamos muy pues muy uno de
la población
1 - muy de 2 o kate entonces estoy aquí
es el resultado padre qué quiere decir
esto que este intervalo de confianza no
sólo es para este parámetro que es un
parámetro raro sino que también es un
intervalo de confianza del 95% para este
para la diferencia entre las medias
reales este es el verdadero parámetro
que nos interesa indica realmente la
diferencia de pérdida de peso entre
tomar la dieta 1 la dieta que es baja en
grasa y no tomar esa dieta que es baja
en grasa
entonces tenemos una confianza del 95
por ciento de caer entre 0.7 y 3.2 y
está bueno porque pues con 95% de
confianza vamos a perder más en la dieta
1 digo no estamos 100% seguros pero 95
por ciento pues 95 por ciento está
bastante bien lo bueno espero que esto
expliqué un poquito más porque está
padre haber hecho el ejercicio pasado y
también espero que en el vídeo anterior
no te haya confundido mucho con mi
lenguaje revuelto y enredado